the russian invasion of ukraine uh
started off with maximalist objectives
uh attempting to basically take uh key
cities while essentially overthrowing
the government uh by taking out local
and national leadership with infiltrated
teams of special forces and airborne
forces inserted
when that didn't work in fact it failed
pretty catastrophically
the russian army was in a position where
it really wasn't prepared to fight
a major campaign against serious
resistance in the roughly nine axes of
advance that they attempted to push
things in with
unfortunately for the russians
unfortunately for the ukrainians
the losses that they took in the first
phase were so extreme that actually
russia's been unable to generate a
sufficient concentration of combat power
to complete those encirclements and so
what we've seen over the second phase is
those encirclement objectives getting
progressively less and less ambitious to
the point that they're now trying to
encircle and take basically just svera
donetsk in the extreme east having taken
popassna which is a small town to the
south of it but which has kind of
commanding and higher ground
which overlook the supply routes into
interstellar nets
the ukrainian forces look like they're
having serious problems holding sierra
de svera donetsk now um partly because
the russians have artillery site of
those supply routes um but even
assuming that they lose it
their positions in kramputs consortium
so still core uh cities in the jfo area
are are still pretty strong and so
uh russia looks like it's kind of
culminating in terms of of where how far
it can push in really quite a minimalist
area right in the east but they probably
will be able to take what remains of
luhan's coblast
[Applause]
and so it remains to be seen whether
putin can
claim credibly that that's taking the
han score blast and
subduing mario paul whether that is kind
of a win condition i mean it looks like
they're in this for the long haul
because that's that's there's no
universe in which that's a credible uh
incredibly worth all of the the massive
losses as well as the huge economic hits
and political hits that russia has taken
over this also remains to be seen where
the ukrainians can actually maintain uh
counter-offensive pressure
east of kharkiv and uh in the south
around carson if they can then the
russians will actually probably struggle
to hold what they've got um but of
course the ukrainian losses are
difficult to to estimate because ukraine
has been good at concealing them so it
may be that ukraine is also close to
culminating in terms of what it can
sustain in high intensity fighting right
now um albeit it's mobilized far more
people than russia
so there's a lot to play for in the next
few weeks because if ukraine can keep up
the pressure russia may actually
struggle to hold what it has if not then
we'll probably see a kind of new line of
contact and a sort of slow additional
struggle over a long period um across
basically your hans goblust and down
into the south where russia will hold
that and ukraine holding most the rest
of the country
you